when they say the jury to not be biased
by like what they hear outside it's like
no but you will you're a human being
what are you talking about yeah it's
like oh don't watch the Netflix
documentary about this case it's like
I'm gonna I'm watching it on my phone
right now I'm gonna go with the opinion
of the director I don't care as a human
your humanness of you your individual
narcissism that we all have takes over
you're like I don't care what happens to
this person I want to get out of here
right so I'm going to vote guilty even
though I don't think he's guilty to get
the at it or vote not guilty just so I
can leave so there has to be something
to prevent that I think once you're in
there you're getting wrapped up and it
doesn't you think so I was gonna say
what percentage 40 a day for jury duty
it's insane I would think they have sex
back in the hotel room like you think
there's a love affairs that go on with
the jury and get to know each other in a
fantasy world yeah they definitely do
right but I don't think they're allowed
to I think it's illegal to have sex with
a fellow jury member I don't think you
can have like a hotel room but see let's
see him stop I don't know let's see him
stop me